so there are a lot of problems with our
economy that are only getting worse from
housing to Crime to homelessness to so
much more and today we're having a
discussion with one of the most
outspoken left-wing political
commentators who's made it very clear
he's anti-landlord oh yeah we have a
very unique debate on that one where do
you draw the line between public housing
and becoming a landlord do you think
like a property like this should be
owned by the government housing is a
mechanism for for capital accumulation
has really perverted our understanding
of housing housing should be uh
decommodified anti-capitalist and also a
Democratic Socialist this one is going
to be very unique and if you haven't
seen it already check out last week's
episode with Brett Cooper from the daily
wire who is basically the exact opposite
so we get to see both sides of the
spectrum here but with that said thank
you so much enjoy the first a message
from our sponsor where's Jack we got to
start filming this podcast
first of all Jack that's not true and
second turn down the music we're gonna
get copyright claimed oh Graham don't
worry about it being demonetized that's
sponsor evident sound the best tool for
creators to soundtrack their content
without worrying about it being
demonetized we've been using epidemic
sound for years but before then finding
good copyright free music was difficult
every single track that we found was
either not copyright free or it was just
really bad epidemic sound is music that
actually sounds good they're suspenseful
fun Whimsical foreign or any other genre
you might want to use plus finding the
right soundtrack could really enhance
your video and thankfully epidemic has
40 000 professionally produced tracks in
over 90 000 sound effects that are
exclusive to epidemic sound but my
favorite part has to be the new ear
feature here works like their fine
similar feature which allows you to
highlight a specific part of a track and
search for music that sounds just like
it so if you're a content creator
looking to soundtrack your content
without worrying about copyright strikes
epidemic sound is my favorite
recommendation and with a 30-day free
trial and 50 discount on first
commercial plans
with the link in the description to get
a free 30-day trial and start creating
your best quality content today and now
with that said let's get the podcast I
don't think I could ever go live like
you do man I feel like uh it takes bro
are you stripping that because you say
no free promise oh come on oh okay what
if I want to give him promo
Fairlife is actually pretty fire I mean
their practices
are absolutely the worst by like even
Dairy Farmer standards why
um I think like the conditions that they
keep the cows in is like worse than
other Farms when you learn something
like that I have a lot of vegans in my a
lot of radical vegans in my in my
community one of my main editors is a
vegan uh propagandist actually so
um he constantly tries to sneak in stuff
like that see I've constantly heard bad
things about Nestle oh yeah yeah for
sure what is their deal do you know
anything about them yeah I mean first of
all when you're in the water business
that's uh that's already pretty
unethical you know what I mean what do
they do well I mean it's like something
you need for survival and these guys are
basically going to local resource like a
natural resource shutting off access to
it and then reselling it back to the
people that live there
well yeah I would say that's like kind
of problematic at least but then also on
top of that
um like on the chocolate front they uh
utilize child slave labor however
they Outsource it to uh you know
third-party companies that are
completely beyond their control and uh
the the safety mechanisms that they've
put in place I think it's like the
chocolate Alliance if I'm not mistaken
is like it's like a regular NGO you know
Shady
uh not exactly consistent
um and uh as far as I understand the
United States Supreme Court ruled that
Mars Nestle and other american-based or
multinational corporations that utilize
child slave labor
are not uh legally culpable for any of
the damages if they were to ever be sued
by the child slave laborers interesting
is that because that was a recent
Supreme Court deniability that they
could say well we hired this company and
we're not responsible for what that
company does and if they do that we
don't know about it yeah one of those
it's one of those like oh no I can't
believe the people that we Outsource
this like hiring process in in the
global South is utilizing child slave
labor like
but then again you know you got multiple
states in the United States of America
unwinding uh child labor laws so
things are looking great here wait could
you explain that yeah
um I can I don't want to I don't want to
mess this up here but I think this might
be the first time we've had sources
pulled up like this that's good we know
it's yeah but I I know our Kansas yeah
what some people call Arkansas but I
call Arkansas uh it was uh recently
making a move and I think Idaho as well
is it to lower the age that uh a minor
would be able to work or what is
Missouri independent titles is kids at
work states try to ease child labor laws
at the behest of Industry now this of
course is following like uh a sea of
nlrb Investigations that were conducted
at uh you know poultry plants where
children were found Hyundai had a
facility in Alabama where children were
actually working in the facility
oftentimes these are undocumented kids
um the the uh the Hyundai facilities I
believe in two different facilities they
found children all the way from like 12
to you know 12 year old 14 year olds
working at the facilities on the
assembly line uh there was another
article there was another investigation
conducted where they found that cleaning
companies that they were utilizing late
at night uh were also you know hiring
children
I would love to get more detail about
exactly what they want to do because I
know titles could be one thing a title
could be misconstrued but
I wouldn't be opposed necessarily if
they if they make it easier for a
teenager or someone who wants to work
after school a certain amount of hours
more access to be able to work if they
want to
yeah but again it depends on exactly
what this says I can tell you what it is
11 states have done this and they've
either passed or introduced laws to roll
back child labor laws a push this coming
from industry trade organizations and
conservative legislatures for the
legislators for the most part
um in the past few years those states
have moved to extend working hours for
children eliminate work permit
requirements and lower age for teens to
handle alcohol or work in hazardous
industries that would be an interesting
one because Jack you worked at a
restaurant but you couldn't serve the
alcohol right yes correct until until I
turn 21 but a lot of restaurants like
they don't actually listen to that not
trying to throw my old restaurant onto
the bus here but restaurants don't
really adhere to that yeah it does seem
silly to me that if you have a server
who let's say is 19 years old
and it's waiting on a table they cannot
bring a glass of alcohol to the people
that they're waiting on even if that
person doesn't have a drink like some of
these things I think can be but then
again I come from the perspective of
like I loved working part-time when I
was like late middle school high school
like that was the joy of my existence
was being able to work so I think it
just comes down to like what those
changes are
I think no children should work as a
necessity you know what I mean like
part-time labor
understandable
um if you want to do it
um to learn the value of a dollar or
whatever certainly and a lot of kids
work and they're like you know family
businesses or whatnot
But ultimately I think like
that genuinely harms your your
development your your you know capacity
to learn when you're tired
fatigued and you're you have this
additional burden I think this is a
there's a gigantic gigantic policy
failure I don't mean like
I'm just simply stating that the fact
that that needs to happen in this
country is is pretty up
let's get more on to that before yeah I
just wanted to say sure there is
apparently according to the U.S
Department of Labor a 69 increase in
children employed illegally by companies
since 2018.
you know child labor is on the rise
I had no idea can you tell us a bit
about your background how you got
involved in
twitch and general streaming
um sure take us back from like you know
as a kid so I grew up in Turkey
um to a relatively affluent family and
if you're like even even a little bit
affluent in Turkey because of how
massive the wealth Gap is in a country
like that you're you know you're Caked
Up uh in comparison to like American
Standards where if a similar salary
would not or similar amount of wealth
would not make you uh you know upper
middle class even sure such as the
nature of you know developing nations
um but uh by the time I got to college
my dad lost everything right
um which is fine I mean I still had a
lot of the benefits of uh early
upbringing could you tell us do you mind
telling us how we lost everything or
what future Trading
what what happened in this gambled
basically yeah
have you been doing that for a while and
seen some success and then just kind of
went all in on it or something yeah
pretty much I think I'm not I'm a little
murky on the details like I don't think
he he's never fully like brought it up
you know what I mean
um but he was he was successful I mean
he was like lobbying the Turkish
government you know he was he was uh
like the right-hand man in a holding
group you know what I mean he was like
he had some pretty serious uh jobs
um
but uh once he once he got a little bit
older
and retired
he basically got into that and
lost everything how old were you at the
time
um that was around 17.
um and then 18 when I went to college
when he like full-blown lost it all
not that it really matters because like
like I said I already got the the many
benefits of growing up and and getting
the best education you know what I mean
so at that point it's like
it's fine what other benefits were there
besides a good education
because you you were in the United
States at that point no no no no no no
I'm in turkey at that point okay I came
to America when I was 18. I would visit
the United States sometimes for Summers
and whatnot which I would consider to be
one of the benefits at least you know
what I mean
um but
uh I mean it's just freedom to not have
the the
economic insecurity even as a child even
if you don't recognize it that still
weighs on you you know what I mean in
ways that like your parents will be
depressed in in certain aspects right
like that that's a that's a lift that
people that come from affluent
backgrounds don't have to even think
about it's like a burden that doesn't
exist
didn't have to work you know what I mean
could
um I mean they were very particular
about not getting me uh things that I
wanted but you know ultimately it
doesn't matter because there were so
many amenities that come along with that
that I
um that I benefited from which is
something I talk about regularly I mean
it was a fairly privileged background
yeah and uh you know I
I think that was probably my first uh
that's when I first started developing
an understanding or even recognizing
income inequality was when I switched
over from a private school to a public
one and that's when I realized like oh
like you know The Gardener's kid
and I'm going to the same school and
like
and this was when I was in third grade I
started realizing like damn The
Gardener's kid is not living like I am
at all you know what I mean I think that
was probably my first uh recognition of
of wealth disparity wealth inequality
not like I wasn't like a socialist or
anything right but as a kid
just yeah I was just like why the
does the kid not have anything you know
what I mean Fair yeah like what what
made you say that there think that way
like what was it that that kid was
lacking that you had I mean even like
basic food items you know what I mean
like you bring lunch to school or
there's a there's a commissary at school
I can buy whatever I want he can't you
know what I mean things like that little
things like that made me realize that
that
um there was something that was a little
off what was your sentiment towards it
at the time were you like oh I'm just
happy that I'm one of the people like a
Haver or was it something I mean I was a
kid I didn't really yeah think about it
anything beyond like observing sure yeah
anything beyond the observation I wasn't
like you know
I didn't have a a revolutionary spark
sure that makes sense yeah yeah so then
you're 18. you come to United States
what's what happens there and why did he
come to the United States why here I
always wanted to come to America when I
was growing up so you probably noticed
that I don't have an accent yeah and
also I have a pretty solid understanding
of American culture as well
because I was immersed in it when I was
growing up
many people around the world are
immersed in American culture obviously
it's like you know pretty profoundly
successful
that's why you see the Taliban wearing
like Oakleys and you know what I mean
like these dudes were in a cave you know
three months ago and now they got like
tactical like American rifles vest
they're wearing the the baseball caps
and whatnot and that's that's one aspect
of like how powerful American culture is
um and I was certainly captivated by it
other kids they would ask other kids
like what do you want to be and kids say
I want to be an astronaut I want to be a
lawyer maybe not really or I want to be
an engineer I want to be a firefighter I
was like I want to go to college in
America that was it's so weird when I
think about it but that's all I wanted
to do America represented this Freedom
right the American dream like it was it
was um
it was something I I definitely uh
believed yeah paired up with also the
social conservatism in turkey that was
like developing and and became the
erdogan regime like the changes that I
started seeing
um what were those changes by the way
so Elizabeth type this is a long story
but the zip type erdogan is is kind of
like Donald Trump but more successful
even than Donald Trump
um he basically uh ran on this like uh
anti-western degeneracy we need to go
back to you know uh uh conservative
values while also of course privatizing
a lot of you know key sectors in turkey
that were otherwise nationalized
historically
um he came in did all of that uh and and
of course in order to maintain his
popularity with a so uh with a socially
conservative base of support that was
all around the country and not
necessarily reflected in the big cities
um he had to keep you know ramping up
the intensity talking about how like
Muslims like the real Muslims were
oppressed in Turkey a country with like
98 Muslim you know what I mean but
um that the the elitist western-facing
Muslims were were you know
morally degenerate and ruining the
country they didn't care about the
hard-working real Muslims uh in in The
Villages and in other places or even in
big cities that were not being reflected
in policy
so that was his main method that was his
like culture War basically that he used
to gain prominence and it was very
successful I mean it was pretty
profoundly popular and also profoundly
unpopular as well but he still
maintained like a a coalition of like 51
of the vote fair enough uh throughout
his Reign pretty much
so you know some of the social changes I
observed one of the dumbest ones I guess
but like that I immediately recognized
was I I love uh political cartoons
political satire when I was growing up I
used to read these Comics that would
come out weekly it was like a newspaper
called penguin there was a couple other
ones and they would regularly criticize
that on as political satirists do they
would draw him
as like different animals and he is a
very thin-skinned man as many of these
Petty tyrants are and he sued them he
sued a bunch of them as a matter of fact
and then that was kind of like a turning
point
um we don't have uh an American
understanding of free speech in Turkey
erdogan himself actually went to jail
for a poem and inciting violence uh
originally uh many many years back many
years prior before he actually
um you know ran for any
position of power but uh he was now
weaponizing that against his uh you know
dissenters basically that was one of
those things uh there was a there was an
element in the air of feeling as though
you know alcohol consumption was frowned
upon things of that nature it was never
fully regulated obviously because it's
like a you know pretty solid sector
tourism is something that turkey relies
on heavily
um and you can't really shut that off
right you can't just be like oh we're
not gonna you know you're not allowed
but it basically started giving voice to
more social conservatives who then felt
more empowered to be able to uh you know
reinforce their ideas no matter how
backwards they were
so things of that nature I started
noticing that I didn't like that the
Free Speech conversation is also a major
one considering that uh you know Turkey
does jail a lot of journalists and a lot
of academics like famously but one of
the worst in the country one of the
worst on the planet
um America is still the number one
Jailer across the board but turkey jails
a lot of academics and a lot of like
dissenters basically so
um you know that was not something I was
fond of but you know paired up with that
seeing America as
it's you know this this Beacon of moral
degeneracy that I thought was awesome uh
and and you know rampant consumption
that I also thought was awesome because
I'm a bit of a hedonist uh I I wanted to
come to America it represented the this
like you know this Beacon of Freedom
sure something that a lot of people that
you know actually immigrate to the
United States if they have are fortunate
enough to do so
uh this is a this is a thing that they
see
from wherever they live because there's
so much wealthier yeah
there's so much money and uh opportunity
too that's something that I've seen with
a lot of people who've immigrated here
they're like there's so much opportunity
everywhere you go for sure the
possibilities are Limitless yeah
absolutely in comparison to other
countries yeah oh yeah totally and so
what was your experience then going to
college
um I went to college first I came to
University of Miami it was a degenerate
I partied a lot I had two nines both
semesters my parents were like that is
the most unacceptable thing on the
planet like how dare you they were
already upset that I chose University
Miami over Boston or even George
Washington University where I got like
really fat scholarships from as a matter
of fact
um so when I chose that when I chose the
University of Miami they were already
frustrated what was their reasoning
behind picking Miami I want to have fun
that was it yeah no I 100 my videos of
like spring break there man it looks no
it's crazy was it fun how was it it was
a lot of fun yeah but so was Rutgers
honestly which is where I inevitably uh
transferred to yeah
um and then but Rutgers was in New
Jersey and I hated the weather and I
just did not like living in New Jersey
at all
um throughout that time also I started
slowly but surely that's when I started
to like uh
genuinely recognizing uh what was
profoundly wrong with America
uh one of the one of the most
significant radicalizing components for
someone like myself was Healthcare
like seeing the fact that coming from a
country where there is Private health
care but also Public Health Care to a
certain degree like you can still get uh
you know Public Health Care
um completely free that the government
pays for right
um
seeing that like uh you had to pay an
insane amount of money to just get like
basic procedures I was like oh this is
like unacceptable
and um it didn't make sense to me at all
I always are also had a negative opinion
of America's foreign policy as someone
who didn't live in America so that was
already there and that's when I started
uh you know moving more into my current
beliefs what about foreign policy do you
think was was the most broken from your
perspective I mean where do I begin
everything America does is pretty awful
in terms of foreign policy
it's always done at the best of uh not
some like uh you know democratizing
Principle as the way they presented here
but instead to make money for the
military industrial complex which is
like one of our most viable Industries
right and uh you know there's obviously
different layers to it resource
extraction is a huge component
um whether it be illicit and like uh you
know
uh uh not on the books resource
extraction or control like you know
opium fields that uh that are being
controlled or protected by the Marines
that have no clue what they're
doing there in Afghanistan uh even
though that those opiates inevitably
make their way not into America mind you
we have fentanyl that's coming from
China that's different or uh any kind of
other uh natural minerals natural
resources or even uh even maintaining
a country's economic status so that you
can take advantage of the labor force at
a much much uh you know
at a much lower you think America does
that oh absolutely I think I think the
entirety of the West does that and I do
believe that they they do it fairly
deliberately I feel like it's I've
always kind of in the back of my mind
thought about it if you're giving jobs
to these third world countries right
like the little like not like the sewing
jobs and stuff like that like creating
materials and stuff
the sweatshops I wonder if that I always
wondered if that was a ploy to keep them
because it's such low paying jobs it's
just enough to get by and survive to
like make sure that they still stay at
the end of the crack of the Whip or
something that's that's most jobs I feel
like most jobs to pay like 50 to 70k a
year I think it's good enough to keep
someone under submission like yeah oh
yes I would say most jobs keep you just
at the neutral point where you don't
want to leave but it's good enough where
you want to stay that's where I feel
like most okay so you don't want to you
don't want to recognize that you're
you're being bagged into a corner so
much so that you're both hungry and
angry because inevitably you'll bite
back right if you are relatively
comfortable through uh you know a ton a
metric ton of Commodities that you can
consume a cheap cheap consumer goods for
the most part
um you'll you'll forget that the cost of
Health Care is skyrocketed the cost of
college education which is like one of
the most significant at as it stands one
of the most significant ways of upward
social Mobility which is not even that
good anymore right but the prices have
still increased the cost of housing is
is has dramatically increased
um but hey we get really cheap TVs what
I wondered like like how do you solve
that problem because if you just abandon
ship and you take all those businesses
that we're using this resources over
there then they don't have jobs at all
and do you think that they would have to
fend for themselves and then create
something better like internally or do
you think that it's upon their
government to to do something for them I
think China is a pretty good example of
like what has been done
um with respect to taking in foreign
capital and then spreading it out as
best as possible and like immediately
developing uh a lot of the
underdeveloped parts I mean if you look
to like the past 30 years of Chinese
development and you look at the current
Chinese economy in comparison to where
it was before foreign Capital started
flooding in uh and and you know before
they started
taking advantage of their manufacturing
power and also you know ripping the IP
as as uh aggressively as they could
perfectly openly by the way and and our
Capital owners also like the business
owners here know that right it's not a
secret but they still want the cheap
manufacturing so they just were like
yeah whatever who cares
um but I think their development has
been pretty solid as a consequence of
that it's about how evenly you
distribute the resources once you start
getting in a load of foreign Capital do
you trust their numbers though because
I've I've heard quite a bit that they
could manufacture their own profits and
and a lot of the buildings they've built
or built on you know invisible money
that was just
basically taken from the people who
invest and Builders use it and employ
you know plow it into the next
development and I mean I see it I look
at their railroads I look at high speed
rail like if you pull up a map of like
High-Speed Rail in China from 2000 to
now yeah in comparison to you know
High-Speed Rail In America which is not
existing I think that that's like pretty
even development in a country there is
the we were looking at like ghost cities
yesterday yeah because people
immediately are like what about the
ghost cities I think that was a
combination of like make work which I do
think is uh something that every good
government should do make work like busy
work construction being one of those uh
ways of doing that and and uh thinking
that the the population was going to
grow more than it actually did
and uh you know this happens and not
only centrally planned economies but it
happens in America as well
um not to the same degree but a lot of
those ghost cities are now actually
becoming more and more populated because
uh because those there is need for a
developed City like people want to move
to a place where you know if if they
move certain things around and that is
an advantage that centrally planned
economies have if you move certain
things around you can move people there
as well people want to go to a place
where they can get better educational
opportunities for example so that's what
they do they'll be like all right we're
gonna put some really good schools here
so then people start moving into what
was before a ghost City so I think that
there's a lot of confusion and a lot of
chaos uh about what gets talked about
with respect to China
um I mean there are obviously awful
things that the Chinese government has
done just like any other government has
you know make no mistake I'm not
avoiding those realities
um but I think overall they have
developed incredibly well especially if
you look to where they were 20 30 years
ago or where they were 100 years ago I
mean it's it's insane and you know this
is not just my analysis of the situation
if you look to like uh I don't know the
World Trade Organization whenever
someone says capitalism has been
profoundly good in like eviscerating
Global poverty extreme poverty at the
global level they're pretty much just
talking about China like the Chinese
numbers really really Skyrocket that
that performance if you leave China out
of the equation
um and obviously I'm not like
um the World Trade Organization and I
have you know or these institutions have
a profoundly different world view than I
do right but even they recognize that
they just say it's because the
capitalism I say it's because of
resource allocation like a more
equitable distribution of resources
my biggest issue is that we have no way
of verifying what China says is true
and that's my biggest concern have you
ever been to China never I haven't
either I really want to go I just look
at to tier one cities sure and think
that like Shenzhen as far as I've seen
from people that have traveled as far as
I read on on the matter from again
Western Outlets ultimately right which
uh usually will have a bias that is I
would say anti-china because they see it
as like in contention to American uh you
know American power Western power right
um even they recognize the development
so you know I I feel like I feel like
it's definitely there yeah let's get
back on to that after we finish the
story because we left off of you being
like 18 or so in college you end up
transferring to Rutgers what happened
there and then how did you get to where
you are today from that I graduated from
college can't get a job obviously I
graduated with honors actually uh
poli-sci degree what was that what
changed between Miami and Rutgers I just
realized like I have to you know have to
work hard together yeah okay
was there a pivotal moment that happened
for you that was like your wake-up call
or was it just gradual over time no it
was just gradual okay because like I
think
um American school is like fairly easy
in comparison to you know what I had to
learn in school in Turkey
so I was just like really phoning it in
so I decided not to phone it as much you
know what I mean sure so that's that's
pretty much it and when you're a
freshman you don't really know what
you're gonna do so you have to take a
lot of like you know Common Core style
classes and those foundational classes
are often like very difficult
especially if it's not something that
you're truly interested in whereas Poli
SCI was something I was interested in so
it was a lot easier for me yeah like it
came naturally it was the job you wanted
to get so you must have graduated what
2014 or 15. 2013 2013. the job I wanted
to get originally was this is funny a
consultant in one of the big four firms
really so originally I was like this is
I you know I have a poli-sci background
I could probably go to like you know PWC
McKenzie one of those companies you know
what I mean that's what I was like
trying to get hired by but of course
that's all like wheeling and dealing who
you know and I did not know anybody so
they've just I don't even think anyone
even looked at my resume right could it
be GPA too do you have a good grade yeah
like I said I graduated with honors
three seven five got it so you know
that's like been pretty solid yeah I
would say
um
and my dad was like you have to go to
like law school or gonna MBA or
something right okay and I was not
really necessarily interested in that so
I was just like yeah sure I'll study for
a law I still I'll study for my lsats in
California Los Angeles
at the time uh you guys probably know
this but if you don't my uncle has a
YouTube channel called The Young Turks
it was like a 26 person shop it was like
a you know tiny operation not that big
not that media Behemoth or anything
um so I was like yeah I'll just go work
with him do an internship with him
and I'll live in LA and I'll study for
the lsats with I had no interest in
studying for the lsats yeah or going to
law school
um so yeah I started working there and
then I was like yeah maybe I should just
like work with him instead and at first
it was really awful because I had no
money and The Young Turks didn't have
any money either so they were like yeah
we wanna we wanna do uh Biz Dev we want
to do like we want you to fill the role
of someone who would be doing like our
direct advertisement sales in-house
rather than
uh rather than someone who rather than
having Google do it right like bringing
in sponsorships every now and then
rather than you know relying on YouTube
we want someone to do it internally so I
basically set up our in-house
advertisement sales and operations a lot
of cold calling a lot of learning I
didn't know anything about it I just
knew the industry a little bit
but that's how I got my start of The
Young Turks was it like commission based
or was it salary it was supposed to be
like uh commission based but you know
when you put a 22 year old in a job like
that in a position like that and it's
commission based and the product that
you're like trying to sell is kind of
hard to sell because it's like political
commentary political news and you're
going for a lot of like Dr campaigns
right or where uh you know with that's
what you're trying to sell to well I I
had to yeah I had to get like I brought
in like Squarespace Crunchyroll things
like that and and through through like
uh you know they weren't necessarily
tier one uh uh you know ad companies I
would say they weren't like tier one
marketing companies like I would meet up
with them like OMD all these like big
Brands you know I think it was Ogilvy
was another one I can't even remember
now but you know I was cold calling a
lot I was developing relationships with
these people while also simultaneously
on the back end like trying to create a
system like trying to create the
structure so we can like actually
deliver these ads all this stuff
um and I brought in a bunch of I brought
in a bunch of campaign chains but they
were all like you know CTR uh CTR based
like that was the that was the
performance that they wanted and it's
just like the shittiest type of ads I'm
sure you guys have them too still to
this day
um I wanted to do like native
advertising I thought that would be cool
but at the time you know people weren't
really uh willing to take a bet I think
we were too ahead
of the game in that respect
and uh
brought that stuff in but it was so
awful I mean I hated sales what
did you not like about it I just it
sucks man come on you I'm sure you guys
have done sales in some yeah I loved it
yeah I hated it it's just like I
I don't wanna I don't want to be friends
with these people you know what
I mean I just like I feel like you have
to be a sociopath a little bit to be
like really good at it no no no no no it
was an agent I was a real estate agent
for 10 years so that's how I got started
sales before that though it wasn't
really sales but kind of I worked at a
marine aquarium wholesaler so we would
sell fish and coral and it wasn't really
like a sales I didn't have to pitch
anybody but someone would call in and
ask about something and I would describe
it to him over the phone like I didn't
get commissions no inbound requests I
was all I was all out that's
gonna make it obviously less so I mean I
was doing the same thing I was calling
up people from open houses who would
sign in and talk to them but I felt like
sales provides a service where if
they're looking for something if you
could help them Finance something you're
doing them a service so it's very much a
customer service based industry one
other thing I did while all of that was
going on was I always wanted to be on
camera but I was dog like I was so
bad at it right I was not good I don't
think anyone is really that good I love
talking but I was very nervous on camera
at first like when the when the camera
light was on it was a different person
almost I couldn't let my personality out
but at that point I'd realized that like
repetition and hard work for someone
like myself
um I was able to achieve a lot of the
things as long as I just like
Boulder through it you know push push
through it doesn't matter if I suck at
first who gives a it's embarrassing
but it doesn't matter
um so I would present myself as a fill
and host
because I looked at all these other hoes
and it's a YouTube show you know these
guys don't know anything more than I do
they're just you know they're a little
bit more charismatic sure they have more
experience on camera I don't think
they're bringing anything particularly
new to the table it's a YouTube
show you know and I was like I could do
that I want to do that so I would say if
someone needs a fill I'll do it last
second doesn't matter don't care what
the subject matter is I'll read on it
I'll speak on it I'll do it so that's
how I started doing
um and so I started doing more
um you know on-camera appearances at
first was that uh like a teleprompter or
would they give you topping you'd have
to research that and speak on it yeah
yeah no teleprompter at this point okay
and then I uh was was living with one of
The Producers at the time
um for one of the one of the media
properties there uh on the entertainment
side and I pitched him the idea The
Young Turks at this point had no
teleprompter shows I pitched him the
idea of doing a teleprompter show they
had a studio that was basically just
like a Supply Closet I was like I'm
gonna put a green screen in here
and I'm gonna do a show out of this uh
I'm I'm gonna give you like a free show
you know I'm just doing extra work right
and you know it took a lot of convincing
But ultimately he was like sure whatever
I mean we lived together yeah it's uh
you know
I'm greasing his wheels that way I guess
I'm gonna call it the breakdown
and everyone's like oh versus gonna be a
drain on our resources
30 million views every week
it was monetized at that point was it no
oh so this is but it's it's so much
reach for you guys yes wow so you know
it became this thing that was insanely
popular Facebook was skyrocketing like
our Facebook growth was insane
tremendous who is the audience at that
point who the audience was I don't
really know what the demographics were
but I I would say they're still 18 to 35
okay you know like the key Target demo I
probably was a little bit younger like
Facebook at that point was like more
popular I would say than it is now with
younger demographics this is when people
were like moving away they had Snapchat
as an alternative but like there wasn't
that many viable Alternatives right
um and it was it was just doing
tremendously well I was doing these
things where I would just do like a back
and forth with Tommy Lauren
do you guys remember who that is
so we never collaborated but she would
make a video and I would piece by piece
go through her video and just like dunk
on everything she was saying it was I
think like this wasn't as popular as it
is now as everyone does it now right
everyone does it on Tick Tock everyone
does it on YouTube but at the time it
was like kind of unique especially to
the political sphere and it was still
scripted it was still teleprompted and I
had like all these assets that I would
bring in
um and it and it was really
it was
for a brief moment I think I captured
the attention of like a massive group of
people
but it was still under the tyt umbrella
I did not have any ownership of this IP
I did not have anything what's like I
have no control over it you know what I
mean and I would constantly say give me
more funds so I could hire a writer give
me more fun so I can like beef up this
process
um and instead of doing that what a tyt
do
they said
no we're just gonna take the breakdown
your baby your child this thing that
you've made and we're gonna make all the
other hosts do it
as well which will dilute the the brand
and what my vision for it was uh so now
you have to train everyone just like
you've trained your editors to be able
to do this kind of content
and you have to also help them you know
make the show because my job isn't
making a show my job at that point is
building our Facebook operations right
like growing our Facebook operations
I hated that
that was when I realized like fully that
I just have no control over my life
whatsoever
this is a reality that many people face
and unfortunately can't really Escape
because you know they can't become
entrepreneurs because that is a you know
massive massive risk it was one that I
was able to do
um eventually I by January 2020
uh before that I I went part-time with
The Young Turks because uh I I wanted my
own thing actually I'm getting ahead of
myself here a little bit I'm jumping
um
what ended up happening is I
realized I needed my own thing after
that when they did that I I needed to no
longer be in the shadow of The Young
Turks no longer being the shadow of my
uncle because no matter what I did
everyone was like nepotism that's the
reason why you're successful nepotism
that's the reason why you're Facebook
you know shit's popping off nebotism
it's like well he's not doing
Facebook videos like what do you mean he
literally can't like you know
um so I was always like trying to move
the audience from tyt properties to
something that I own like you know my
Instagram yeah
they were not too fond of that at first
they didn't give a but then they
realized like oh this guy's like
kind of using our Network to like build
his own brand I don't like it
um then I started twitch
because I was very bad off the cuff I
wanted a place where I could go to every
day build a community around it I wanted
something that was mine
and I wanted to be able to start
speaking off the cuff what better way to
learn how to speak off the cuff than
speak off the cuff for eight hours a
day to an audience even you know
have a back and forth
and I also was a gamer already and I saw
the gaming space as one that was like
actually very diverse and had a lot of
like Progressive opinions but
unfortunately if you looked at like the
gaming adjacent content creators none of
them were really openly leftists or
anything like that they were all
actually very right-wing you had the you
had a lot of like actually far right
content creators even that were doing
like commentary and essays so we're you
know gamergate had happened and everyone
was talking about like you know how
video games are political and and that
meant like there was like a black woman
in the video game you know what I mean
Not Call of Duty though Call of Duty was
not considered political
um
so it was a lot of commentary like that
which is why I was like no there's
there's uh there's definitely demand for
this
um my kind of politics with my
understanding of memes internet culture
all that sort of stuff and twitch was
the best place to go to do that because
it was a video game platform so that's
when I made the move to start doing my
twitch which was very tiny at the time
wasn't anything and I started building
it up slowly but surely and by the time
2019 came around it was at least like
respectable you know what I mean I was I
was reaching like sometimes 5 000
concurrent videos oh wow that's high
more than respectable yeah that's really
good I mean well in comparison to where
I'm at now it was at the time it was
like not that big right
um how are people finding you at that
point was it just twitch was pushing you
to the top because people no
a big part of it was networking there
were content creators that I
collaborated with
um that I I basically would do content
with it was a mutually beneficial
situation train wrecks TV was one of
them that does like debates or what did
with hosts like this podcast that was
live I would go on that all the time
there was another show uh by a friend of
mine who I now do a podcast with called
uh well at the time I've had a different
name his name is Austin show
um he had like these massive uh debates
for that that you know basically
everyone on the platform would be
watching at the time it was like 35k
live concurrent viewership which was
like you're maxing out at that point
right
for any kind of like non-fort night you
know non-gaming uh content
and um
that's pretty much how I how I uh grew
up uh my my uh platform there was
another content creator who no longer
friends with but Destiny who's who I
collaborated with a lot as well yeah
early on so how often were you working
at the YouTube channel and doing twitch
how did you balance the two I it was
probably 2019 was probably the worst
there was no balance
no time for friends no time for
relationships no time for family I would
wake up at around 5 30 in the morning
start reading and writing my script I'll
go into the studio shoot the video I
have all the assets prepared
would drive back home after 2 2 p.m it
was like usually you know it was 6 37 to
2 p.m is what my working time frame was
for The Young Turks um but then I was
still on call you know what I mean it
wasn't like I was done right I I would
have to upload the video myself to
Facebook that was my job as well I would
have to do the SEO for it thumbnails all
that sort of stuff make the thumbnails
make the SEO
um and I would drive back home take my
dog to the dog park make my first meal
of the day basically cook it as quickly
as I could go work out at the gym
and while I'm doing all of that uh by
the time you know it was like 5 p.m at
this point basically you know the video
would be ready to publish publish the
video go live on Twitch and then from
like 5 PM 6 p.m till like 11 p.m I was
live streaming on Twitch as many hours
as I could what was the motivation for
doing that was it to build Twitch up
enough that you could leave
the motivation was so that well one I uh
the motivation was that I I wanted a
place that I could like go back to like
a a community you know what I mean
um another motivation for me was just
like you know have some Independence
outside of The Young Turks like a brand
uh of my own you know something that
people can point to and say that's
Hassan that's a song not at the
Young Turks like individually that's
fair so that was my most uh you know
those were the the primary motivators
and also be able to learn how to speak
how much were you making at the time
between working like what seems to be 16
hour days like every single day before I
left uit I think my salary was around
like 65 Grand sure which you know for La
standers is not great
um
and on top of that it was like whatever
I was making on Twitch I think I said I
would go independent like I started
thinking or teasing out like possibly
going independent
um was it five thousand subs or ten
thousand Subs I can't remember which you
know after the twitch pay cut is a lot
of money is like another additional on
top of that like around what is it like
20 grand 25 Grand
um something like that
um so you know that was that was I
thought enough uh for me to
withstand the the possibility of like
losing health care and everything else
which was something that I had to you
know struggle with it was something that
I was genuinely fearful of yeah
something that a lot of people have to
think about if they have to make that
jump on their own
so
that's uh that's how that worked out for
me so when did you make the jump
full-time to Twitch August 21st 2019
comes around yeah and I say something
that in a heated gaming moment
that uh I still stand by in principle
and also like uh you know as long as I
elaborate what it what the intention
behind what I said was
said America deserve 9 11. oh I've yeah
I've seen that clip everyone's seen that
clip at this point I mean that went
on Fox News I remember being
terrified like uh it immediately
keemstar elevated it then like I mean
people clipped it out keemstar escalated
it it just elevated it put it out there
you know
broad daylight and in that in a span of
24 hours it was on Fox News it made it
to Tucker Carlson it made it to Laura
Ingram Laura Ingram was calling Dan
Crenshaw in
to like respond to it because I also
said some stuff about Dan Crenshaw as
well and I remember thinking like I'm so
I'm I'm killed I'm gonna be
murdered well I you know I I'd been
getting death threats at that point
pretty regularly but like
it was on Fox News Now how many people
were watching you when you said that
live I don't remember but it wasn't that
big it just like doesn't matter once
it's out there it's like yeah it doesn't
matter once once you that's how this
works you know it doesn't matter you you
got 2 000 people let's say watching or
five thousand people let's say watching
and then it gets in front of a much
larger audience of people that are like
oh this guy he's Muslim socialist
guy he's saying America deserve 911 he
like loves Al Qaeda you know what I mean
which wasn't my point at all it was
actually the opposite but that made its
way to Fox News and I remember thinking
oh if Fox and it's if Fox and
Friends covers this
in the morning I know Donald Trump
watches Fox and Friends if Fox and
Friends covers this in the morning I'm
screwed because Donald Trump
might tweet about it and if he does that
I'm dead like they're gonna murder me
like there's no way I survived that
right
um
and it was probably one of the worst uh
weeks months of my life it's something
that you know people still bring all the
time but I didn't really give a uh
but uh at the time
I was still look at tyt guy
and so people were setting death threats
to like everyone at The Young Turks like
literally everyone down to like the key
grip you know what I mean like they
found anyone and everyone that works at
the Young Turks and would like docs them
and say that they're gonna come
murder them
um that's when I realized like you know
maybe I should uh
do this on my own like I don't want
other people to be suffering the
consequences of my stupid mouth
and not being able to like fully uh
elaborate on on things or not get clip
chimped really what were you trying to
get across when you said that comment
you know the 20th year uh the 20th
anniversary of 9 11 really uh was an
interesting moment for me because
everything that I've said at that on
that broadcast
basically uh things that I already knew
was reinforced through every documentary
that came out in that in that time frame
talking about our uh arming and
radicalizing of the mujahideen uh in the
lead-up to the civil war in Afghanistan
and the US is our invasion of
Afghanistan and how much the CIA very
openly uh elevated these these otherwise
like random groups of militants into a
viable and robust anti-soviet uh violent
Force they did it through uh you know
Islamic fundamentalism that they
instilled upon uh people then
legitimized
um and then some of those groups became
the Taliban right they started
infighting some of those groups again
the Taliban and America was directly
involved in this and very openly
um even before uh Ronald Reagan famously
brought them to the White House and said
they reminded the mujahideen reminded
him of the founding fathers
um so that's what I was talking about
because it was in response to what Dan
Crenshaw was saying about how you know
9 11 happened because they hate us
like they hate us because they hate us
that's it and it was uh it was very
frustrating for me to see like a dude
who went served overseas got his eye
blown out right to to come back and just
like keep reinforcing that same cycle of
violence uh and even using his like
veteran status as a way to just like
send more men and women overseas to get
their blown off for no
reason you know what I mean
so you're saying they have a reason to
dislike us but not deserving to happen
to innocent people
yes I never I never meant that obviously
like the 3 000 people that died on 9 11
deserve to die that's ridiculous
I was simply talking about America's uh
chickens coming home to roost you know
what I mean this is a this in at least
in academic circles or even in most
circumstances this is something that
like every American kind of understands
and and recognizes you know what I mean
like we constantly their up
over there eventually some of those guys
are going to come back and like you know
do do a little bit of whiplash like come
back and and strike back right
um that was the point
many such examples it's a concept called
blowback
um and uh
and I think the the uh
the way that the media actually started
covering in the 20th anniversary of of 9
11 and the Afghan Invasion reflected all
of the talking points that I was making
at the time
which is why I had a lot of people
actually come back and be like listen I
misunderstood what you were saying at
the time but I totally get it now
did that not make you really concerned
about what you say when you go live and
how things could be taken out of con did
you change the way that you would speak
after that to be more careful or
considerate of like you have to be very
literal in what you say because things
will be taken out of context absolutely
I uh I call it Twitter speak there's a
way that people speak if they're on
Twitter all the time where they want to
make sure that nothing that they say can
be uh you know intentionally
misconstrued
um and if you ever use like any kind of
spicy language or if you embellish it
all if you exaggerate like people will
weaponize that against you they'll use
it against you
um it's it's certainly something that I
uh I I
have have cared about a lot more yeah
like I take into consideration a lot
more now I'm also curious did any of
that online hate translate in person I
mean I don't usually talk about that
because you know I don't want to I don't
want to give any power to it but it's
just uh you know it is what it is okay
it happens got it but uh no for the most
part uh out in public when I meet people
uh no it's a overwhelmingly positive
experience it's always just like you
know people that work at the restaurants
I go to or you know people that are uh
Union activists and leaders that are you
know saying look I love your I love your
show uh you gave me the confidence to go
out and and you know fight for my rights
in the workplace things of that nature
it's it's usually it's overwhelmingly
positive yeah and what was the outcome
of like your next live stream after that
comment well they got banned you got
banned for a week yes because you know
obviously when when you know when
when something that you say uh on a live
stream becomes a matter of national news
especially in a negative way you're
probably gonna get banned which
immediately took action got banned for a
week
um
and then I uh you know I came back and
when you get banned and you come back a
lot of there's always like a big boost a
lot of people pay attention to that so
this is something I actually wanted to
get your opinion on universal basic
income what are your thoughts on that
um because that would give a lot of
people that autonomy to be able to be
their own boss to a certain extent and
to pursue other creative Ventures Ubi is
actually a very good idea but it can be
a very bad idea as well what do I mean
by that Ubi is uh the problem with Ubi
is that if it's used
as a way to further the social
safety nets the existing social safety
nets that are already in a state of
disarray then it's not good just a cash
injection with no that that basically
eats away at like EBT SNAP credits and
and you know Social Security and whatnot
would be devastating because I feel like
that would open up the avenue to further
privatize these uh institutions that the
government is supposed to be controlling
so that is something that I'm very
fearful of but as a concept of Ubi on
top of that was supplementary great um
let me ask you this do you feel like a
person would be able to better manage
money like that than the government
would like let's just say hypothetically
you do get rid of all the other social
services but in its place you go right
to the person you say you get twenty two
hundred dollars a month or two thousand
dollars a month no you don't feel like a
person would benefit absolutely some
people might but no
I'm of the mindset that people are not
very smart and as a whole and when we're
when we think about every single person
I'm a dumbass okay I don't want to
manage all of that stuff someone should
manage all of that stuff and I think
that leaving it up to a a governing body
is always going to be especially I mean
even though it's like devastatingly
crippled awful uh for the most part it's
not significant enough I still think
that uh having it be regulated uh
through a
a body that is still somewhat
accountable through the Democratic
processes is the is the right thing to
do in theory in practice obviously our
institutions are are purposely crippled
undermined underfunded
um and uh left to starve and die out so
that you can privatize it basically but
I am I am uh I'm a firm believer that
you know having that uh having that
safety net is is really really important
there are plenty of examples of this
being super successful I mean every
Nordic country that you look to social
democracies that you look to in Europe
there are you know
very different ways of doing things but
ultimately the the principle behind it
is still the same socialization is is a
a necessity I would say and yeah what
things do you think should be socialized
I think healthcare is one of one of the
items that you mentioned I don't know
what I'm about to say and I know what
you're about to say yeah but you know if
we could talk more time to talk about it
yeah so uh yeah I think I mean I things
that have inelastic demand
Necessities for survival
should certainly have at least like uh
comfortable bottom that the government
should provide
what do I mean by this I I'm not saying
that we should like completely eradicate
the private sector in all aspects of our
development or all all aspects of
commodity develop you know commodity
production
um well maybe in the future that could
be something that we could do not in the
short term of course
um but
Healthcare certainly should be
nationalized but you can't nationalize
Healthcare without also having free
college because you don't want doctors
to get you know into five hundred
thousand dollars in debt and then go
work at a you know go work at a public
facility for pennies on the dollar and
and not be able to even pay that debt
back
um plenty of countries have recognized
this and that's the reason why they also
offer free education uh even America has
kind of been forced to recognize this
reality uh and you know you see schools
like NYU and and New York schools like
New York colleges trying to create a
scholarship process so that you know
doctors can get educated for free or at
least like have heavily subsidized
education
um
I also think you know what I want to say
housing should be uh decommodified
what do I mean by that I think we all
agree that housing should I mean housing
is a necessity for survival for that
reason I believe that
um housing is a mechanism for for
capital accumulation
has really uh perverted our
understanding of Housing and has created
glaringly obvious uh problems in America
but especially in a place like
California where uh what is it 43.7 or
43.7
uh
people for every like hundred thousand
people is is homeless here it's like an
insane number I don't want to mess the
numbers up yeah but we are number one my
understanding with homeless though is
that a lot of people come to California
specifically because of the weather and
because of some of the social services
that are offered here part of me
believes homelessness is not necessarily
a California problem but it's a
Country-Wide problem someone could be
homeless in let's say Nevada and they
get a one-way ticket to California and
that's Nevada's Solution by the way to
homelessness oh 100 yeah that was
California's delusion to homelessness
was the ship them to Hawaii back in the
day yeah another state a lot of
homelessness I feel like it's it's
California's bearing a lot of the burden
of a nationwide crisis of homelessness
that it's not just because California
real estate's expensive but it's also
because the weather and I think the
location really support people who have
no other place to live but on the street
because of the weather
there is some truth to the way that like
Texas or red States deal with
homelessness is a problem what you're
what you're mentioning there's truth to
that but ultimately
um there are countries that have been
able to eviscerate homelessness without
shipping them to other places you know
what I mean uh countries that do a much
better job
uh of tackling the issue through policy
uh then then we do here in California
and it's not like they're killing their
homeless people like
they're housing them yeah uh and the
reality is that uh you know public
housing as or or even like uh like
decoupling housing from uh the profit
motive is is 100 a necessity to solve
uh homelessness because other than the
people that are being shipped to
California let's say the reason why we
have so many homeless people here is
because
and I work with a lot of uh you know
people that do activism in this field
that work with homeless people uh in
general
um it's it's the number one factor is
that they get priced out of the housing
market so I call this the different
tiers of homelessness because the most
public-facing side of homelessness is
oftentimes the the uh the person that
you see on the street that has like
leathery skin at this point from being
under the Sun from sun damage sun
exposure for many many years who clearly
is not mentally well right
um that is the last tier of homelessness
that is the the uh type of homelessness
that like this person is going to be
profoundly hard to recover and
profoundly hard to reintegrate into
society and and needs a lot of work
um that number is growing in California
as well but there is an invisible side
of homelessness that a lot of people
don't even recognize that actually makes
up the largest percentage of homeless
people the invisible homelessness comes
from people who are housing insecure
people who are couch surfing people who
are living in their cars but still keep
up appearances have a job people that
don't have access to like uh you know
don't have immediate access to like
running water right but can still figure
it out by like going to the gym and like
having a gym membership living in their
car but then you know cleaning
themselves up before a job interview or
you know before going into work
that is the first stage of homelessness
that's the most common version of
homelessness that is the most
recoverable form of homelessness and
that is almost entirely due to you know
obviously market conditions as well like
you know the job sector layoffs things
of that nature but the most common
reason for that homelessness to exist
the largest pocket is that they get
priced out of the housing market they uh
have a job but they their commute
expands dramatically let's say
um and that actually makes it more
costly for them when they live like you
know uh 40 50 minutes away ruins the
quality of life but let's say we don't
even care about that at this point
um
they they're forced to move somewhere
far away and they can't keep the jobs
that they originally had the job still
exists but it's much much much more
difficult to uh you know go to it now
a lot of people have a hard time keeping
jobs like that they get fired
um all of a sudden you know you you no
longer have access to you know clean
water you have your car
uh you're having a hard time you're
being harassed by cops regularly because
you can't park everywhere you know what
I mean you're you're being called a
vagrant whatever
then you move into tier two homelessness
which is also another massive pocket
where it becomes permanent like your
condition basically becomes permanent
now
one thing that I always like to stress
is that you know even bears and animals
in the wild need shelter for survival
you need a cave right you need
something to burrow inside of you don't
just like Brave the elements
and as humans I I feel like we're all
you know I don't know if you guys are
vegans or not but like we're all a
little bit specious right we think
humans are the apex predator we think
we're a little bit better off than like
you know monkeys and and the like
we are
um when you are shut off from having
access to shelter
with no recourse with no way of like
recovering that over an extended period
of time that is an insanely traumatic
experience you start developing PTSD
there's a lot of crime that goes on in
homeless communities as well uh there's
back and forth assault rape uh and the
like and then
um you also don't have access to health
care obviously so you start both
self-medicating
in some ways and also simultaneously
trying to make money
start selling drugs start taking the
drugs you start selling the drugs and
that completely built like paired up
with the trauma of not having shelter
and not having any job opportunities
pushes you into the last the final stage
of homelessness where you see like a lot
of mental illness a lot of drug abuse
and even more assaults and even more uh
you know rape and horrific things that
people have to go through yeah I've
definitely seen a very extreme side of
things growing up and living in West L.A
um up until really 2020 where most of
the people that I would see visually I
think had a mental illness were severely
addicted to drugs and I think there's no
resources out there that address those
and there was a property that I was
considering purchasing that was right by
Venice Beach and it was down the street
from the new homeless shelter that was
there that was the one that everyone was
upset about because it was in the middle
of Venice and I think the average cost
was like 500 000 a room people said why
do they need to be right in the middle
of event at such a high cost and the
benefit would be if you sold that to a
developer the money that that person
would bring into the community could
more than pay for so much more shelter
why is it here but I remember following
up on that because I knew it was such a
big deal for that community and
throughout a lot of the process it was
never more than I believe 60 occupied
because they enforced a dry policy that
you could not uh bring in drugs alcohol
be drunk
um you're nailing it this is this is
you're absolutely correct but I've also
seen a side of it where people just
did not want to assimilate back into a
community that they felt more free I'm
not saying this is everyone but they
felt more free not you know
participating in society and having that
uh Freedom really to to do it what
you're describing is is actually 100
correct
homeless shelters are actually more
violent spaces for a lot of homeless
people than than the opposite you would
think like what the that's a
shelter that's like so much better it's
not it's actually where the where a lot
of the assaults and a lot of the
robberies are committed
um and on top of that uh if you have
items that you care about or even like a
dog for example you can't bring your dog
and you can't you have to go cold turkey
if you're on drugs
um if you have any sort of like abuse
and substance issues you have to go Cold
Turkey
um so a lot of people choose not to do
that and while we all probably looked at
that and go oh off you don't have
any rights you know why go to
the shelter and fix yourself up the
reality is that that is actually as far
as like a compassionate and more ethical
approach to homelessness the the reality
is that this is why a lot of people
advocate for housing first homelessness
policies where
um
where where people have some semblance
of autonomy still to to begin the
healing process the mental health and
and the you know substance abuse therapy
process
um uh that that is a more permanent and
also a more secure way to deal with this
uh with this issue but that's on the
tackling the the existing homelessness
part what I was talking about with
respect to housing is usually tackling
it on the other side because there's two
sides of this rope you gotta you gotta
shut off this part and you got to shut
off this part this part is being caused
by uh you know this part is being caused
by uh a a lack of access to like
affordable housing and being priced out
of the housing market this part is just
way more complicated you have to
actually convince uh people to to go
into housing even if you offer permanent
shelter sometimes almost people don't
want it they don't trust it and they're
scared and and you know there is a there
is a mechanism of enforcement that you
need to engage with there but I mean
that requires hiring a load of
social workers and and uh you know
genuinely trying to tackle this issue
instead of just kind of you know playing
uh chicken with uh with the homeless
encampments and just like pushing them
one street over and then being like Oh
we solved the problem you know what I
mean like look I mean that's certainly
something but where should that be for
homeless should that be in the Pacific
Palisade should that be Beverly Hills
what's to say it shouldn't be in Santa
Monica but it's okay in Riverside I
think that it should be wherever
homeless people are I think that um as
far as like it's not even shelters uh
housing first policies should exist in
in most communities I uh I think that it
would genuinely in the long term benefit
those communities because then you just
don't have homeless people in the
countries let's say suffocating
yeah let's say Santa Monica would be a
prime example of that yeah it brings in
a lot of business a lot of Technology a
lot of really wealthy people if you were
to put
a community of homeless people in the
middle of that and say this is where
they are and therefore that's where we
should build for homeless it would drive
out a lot of the people because they
would feel less safe
um they wouldn't want to do business
there and I feel like property taxes
housing I'd probably make the housing
market a little bit better in Santa
Monica well the issue well then you get
property values going down you get less
Commerce in Santa Monica the area slowly
generates and I feel like then that
would continue to spread so like overall
the benefit would be lower than if you
say we're going to put money into mental
health into drug addiction it doesn't
need to be in the middle of the city but
it could exist over here where land is
more affordable and our uh our
opportunity cost is lower if that makes
sense well the way I see it as someone
you know who owns a house in West
Hollywood as someone who uh lived in
these neighborhoods that you speak of as
well I lived in Brentwood before uh in
in you know more affordable apartments
which was awful so expensive
yeah but still incredibly expensive with
many many roommates
um I think that the option is
do you want homeless people to keep
moving around and on the
streets or do you want them to in
the toilet with a roof over their head
and I think like if that is the
alternative and what you bring up with
Venice is actually a good idea because I
mean a not a perfect solution because
ultimately that didn't eradicate
homelessness in Venice right
um
but uh with with
some genuine changes into the way that
like the shelter's process works with
like hopes for permanent shelter
Solutions yeah which currently are
non-existent I think that uh it doesn't
matter where you put these these places
like it doesn't matter where you have
um you know rehab facilities for example
because like think about it this way
property in Malibu is so expensive right
well you know what Malibu has a
on a rehab facilities does that change
the property value no why because the
people that are going to those rehab
facilities are rich people they're the
rich people rehab facilities so they
also aren't necessarily the ones
defecating on the street and I feel like
the defecating on the street usually is
an indicator of severe mental illness to
the point where they cannot function on
their own without assistance and those
would not be the people who could
voluntarily go and like I'm gonna also
that's not entirely correct either not
100 but I would say because in a lot we
don't have public bathrooms you know
what I mean where the is he
supposed to right yeah you're
talking about the extremes where you
know I used to work in West Hollywood
and I would see people out front on
Sunset Plaza pulling their pants down in
front of traffic and just
yeah
um yeah people are are severely and and
like genuinely cripplingly mentally ill
due to the circumstances that I
described
um and those people need help and part
of that help comes from again
like not directly institutionalizing
those people but some level of
institutionalization
in a a significantly more empathetic and
significantly more compassionate and
more ethical ways I would agree with
that and and I think that this is
something that like everyone kind of
agrees on yeah but there's a very uh you
know it's a very shitty part of this
conversation that uh we will never agree
on which is the unfortunate reality that
like housing prices might need to be
devalued a little bit in the process of
like building or or
um not completely abolishing zoning
restrictions in its entirety but at
least like allowing for uh or or
allowing for certain types of housing to
be developed in communities California
has a 55 home ownership rate homeowners
are very powerful as an as an entity
here in this in the state
they don't want any housing they don't
want any housing no I agree with you on
that that's something that I've said is
that the building process in Los Angeles
specifically is so terrible it is so bad
I made a video on this years ago about
the process it takes to build a
multi-family building here in LA
the amount of open space that you need
to account for the amount of parking
parking is a huge one even if you're
close to nearby Transit you need a
certain amount of parking spaces for the
amount of bedrooms that you have per
square foot in addition to Common space
open area all of these things that make
the cost so unbelievably High to build
any sort of multi-family here in Los
Angeles and so for a developer for it to
even make Financial sense to break even
they have to build luxury units that's
the only thing that they could build
otherwise there's no Financial pay would
lose money on that yeah but also
building adus is so difficult in Los
Angeles and they came out with this
program a few years ago saying I
remember we're gonna accept most adus
and I was really looking forward to this
because I have a duplex and I'd love to
turn the garage at that point into
another unit two units and there was a
proposal that would allow you to build
five stories if you were within I think
it was like a mile from a major
intersection or half a mile from public
transit and I was so looking forward to
that because I could take that duplex
and build five to six units and that
would provide a lot more housing and
everyone in my neighborhood would be
able to do that but that failed because
people didn't want and I kind of
understand if if you're a house you
don't want to be necessarily living next
to five stories and have people look
down in your backyard and lose that
privacy and like I get that too but they
make buildings so difficult here in L.A
yeah
um I I agree I think that they do that
deliberately they do that for one
because like uh you know a lot of people
say their quality of life or the the
character of the neighborhood will be
eviscerated destroyed right
um or uh they also don't want their
housing prices to devalue either
technically
uh because now there's more housing
availability you know what I mean or
because they're next to a
building all of a sudden
and to that I say you know yeah there's
going to be some there's going to be a
little bit of struggle there but in the
long term in the long run
it will yield tremendous benefits in the
form of not having
people that have been homeless for five
years six years that's taking a
outside of your house or just like
trying to break into your house
breaking into your car like I've had
I've had all of these things happen
um it's a it's the cost of living in a
big city
it shouldn't have to be there are plenty
of examples of cities that have been
able to eradicate this problem not
entirely but have done a much better uh
you know have dealt with it much better
like what cities
um I am of course going to bring up if
you are not familiar with this I'm
surprised uh red Vienna uh Austria is
the country we're talking about in
Vienna 65 of uh all homes are actually
public housing they are not-for-profit
housing basically it's a it's it's a
concept where the government offers many
benefits to develop housing and then and
then basically have the rent
exist specifically to either further
develop more public housing or to
maintain the housing itself housing that
is not created with the sole purpose of
accumulating uh more value to the single
soul owner or whatever corporation owns
it but instead housing created uh by by
basically taking away some of the
barriers of developing this project that
can only be done by the government like
offering a lot for a dollar
with the express purpose of like
building cooperatively owned housing and
then working with like Credit Unions to
to basically get investment in like to
get a loan from A bank
uh only to have the existing property
once it's you know completed and built
uh and the rent in said existing
property pay for the uh pay for the
mortgage and the maintenance fees I've
seen quite a few countries offer that of
like a dollar but in a lot of those
instances it's usually to promote people
to move into a city that no one else
wants to live in or that is declining in
population they need more people in
there and so they use that as a resort
to say hey come here be no different
than people like you know doing that in
Riverside and saying like hey we want
more people over here we want to be more
of a hub uh but I think Los Angeles and
a lot of California specifically
um in in a higher priced neighborhoods
they want to attract top talent and they
want people like that to move here and
innovate and they don't have a problem
with declining population to that extent
where they have to incentivize people
and land is so expensive I don't think
it should be a bypro Vancouver doesn't
have a declining population uh but it's
not it's not to incentivize more people
to move in it's the basically uh uh it's
used to basically do the the lightest
form of government intervention you can
do
and utilize the same capitalistic system
and the same structures without like
completely undermining it
to offer affordable housing is a
low-cost alternative but because that
system is not funded at all and has
actually been uh you know disfavored by
homeowners and and uh you know all of
these people that are incentivized to
consistently keep their housing prices
up in places like Amsterdam uh the
number of cooperatively owned uh
non-profit housing
units have declined and that's why even
in a place like Amsterdam for example
you see since the 2000s the cost of
living Skyrocket and become a
genuine problem so where do you draw the
line between public housing and becoming
a landlord I mean do you think like a
property like this should be owned by
the government and someone should have
to pay way less because it's owned by
the guy like should someone have the
right to live in West Hollywood for
instance yeah if I think that I think if
if like I am not in the business of like
completely eradicating private home
ownership I am a private homeowner
myself
what I simply want to do is make it
unaffordable for people to generate and
accumulate capital
from a home that they're not living
inside of a home that they're basically
renting out that's what it means to
decommodify housing now that's a very
long-term goal and obviously that's not
going to be happening anytime soon in
the United States of America so the
solutions I present in the interim
period in the short term is to literally
just like eviscerate the problem that
currently exists with homelessness so
let's discuss this on an ethical level
because I think that would be really fun
because I know you two have very
different opinions on the ethics of land
ownership slash obviously being a
landlord Graham has his own unique
experiences because he's obviously a
property owner like that and you
probably have your own respective
opinion let's hear what you have to say
about that I mean I think that um I
think that shutting off a necessary
resource by you know
by making it a profitable business a
profitable Venture is like something
that I'm entirely against if you want to
still you know do that
uh you know you could do commercial real
estate which is up different because
yeah but let's say it's a mom-and-pop
business how is that any different from
a household I feel like a like a
a family is also a business they have to
run a business just the same way as a
mom and pop liquor store on the corner
would have to run a business you're
taking in money you have expenses you
have to save a little bit for a rainy
day yeah wouldn't that be the same thing
no because you don't have to live inside
of your your you don't have to live
inside of your uh business in the same
way a business can Thrive and survive
even if the the barrier in that regard
exists right a business can still uh
get a bank loan to be able to pay for
these sorts of things whereas like I
think the similar process should not
exist for home ownership wouldn't that
be wouldn't getting a loan be the same
thing as renting a house from a landlord
because then you're owing money to
someone else probably the government who
you're going to be paying five to seven
percent interest to yeah I mean in some
respects absolutely well obviously we
don't have like Soviet block style
public housing in this country so I'm
just simply saying that like in the
short term these are the uh this is what
I advocate for in the short term to like
at least tackle some of the issues with
availability of housing that creates
homelessness from my perspective I see
landlords as providing a service and and
I'm trying not to like include the
slumlords because there's certainly
people that do the bare minimum like
just basic above like the bare minimum
living conditions to try to maximize
profit but yeah talking about like a lot
of landlords that I see
the vast majority of your mom and pop
they own three or fewer properties they
a lot of times have owned properties
from their parents they just turn into
rentals they've they own up the house
instead of selling it they'll choose to
rent it out to someone else will they
buy something else and then eventually
rent that but from what I've seen and
what what I've seen a lot of people do
is that they'll buy a property that that
no one else would consider and these
would be properties that need a lot of
work that maybe an owner users doesn't
have the funds to fix up they don't have
the time they don't have the interest
someone else goes and fixes that up and
rents it out to someone who doesn't want
to own a home and there's a lot of
people out there that renting is more
beneficial than owning if they're only
going to live there for a few years if
they just want to test out an area home
ownership is is is really burdensome as
I'm sure you've seen with property taxes
Insurance repairs so miscellaneous
things right now it's cheaper to rent
than it is to own throughout the
majority of losses I think ultimately
the sense of security that you get from
having permanent shelter when you're a
homeowner is is you know much much
better overall than than having the fear
of you know your landlord literally
changing your rent just because they can
because the market conditions are
favorable to to do such a thing
um and uh regardless of that though I
mean like I said uh public housing does
not necessarily have to mean permanent
shelter in the sense that like you own
the house that you're in
um Singapore I think has a system
similar to that as well where you're
basically leasing it for the government
right
um
and and you know these are places where
they've been able to tackle this
crisis head on before it even existed
and it still works on a rental basis if
you want the opportunity to rent a home
you can absolutely do so
um I guess the way I see the world is
that
um I wish for a future where people
don't even need to be mom and pop
landlords uh as a as a nest egg for
survival that like they they like they
don't need to even do that because a lot
of those things are taken care of
through social safety nets when you are
no longer a productive laborer when you
have retired but of course that is a
load of other issues as well how
would that play in though if you want a
higher quality of living beyond that
let's say let's say that you don't want
that and you want to be able to make
more money or work harder and get
something nicer
then go ahead I mean it's not I'm yeah
what I'm talking about with respect to
like full-blown decommodetized uh
decommodifying housing is again so far
out in the future that it's like
unimaginable to talk about from today's
standards of living and the way that we
experience Society right now because
there are other complications that uh
that that exist there like for example
housing is not the only issue uh part of
the the problem that I mentioned is
commutes and travel right one way to
make traffic congestion uh infinitely
more uh infinitely better and more
livable in a place like California is
public transit we're very spread out but
unfortunately we also have made zero
attempts to better our public transit
system in this in the state in general
and certainly not in Los Angeles
um that is also a necessity walkability
like making walkable cities and and
making this City more walkable and
simultaneously have better public
transit options is an absolute necessity
for low-income people to survive I would
love to see micro Apartments I'm talking
like 300 250 square foot that's what I
would have loved when I was 20 21 years
old you're working all day you're out
and about you could live in the central
part of wherever you want to live and
that's all you need you need a bed a
kitchen a TV bathroom 300 square feet I
no I I don't think I don't think that's
a solution I mean it's just like sure if
you if you want to create an opportunity
for like cheaper living that's fine
that's great but like I don't even think
when I say affordable housing when we
talk about like again going back to
Vienna 65 public homeowner like publicly
owned housing availability
those massive complexes that we're
talking about are like Luxury
Condominiums in comparison to what we
have here as as available in the private
Market
um they have they have gyms they have
pools they have uh some some sunlight
coming in
um and and you know a balcony that you
can you know build like a
some kind of Shrubbery on you know like
just some some green
um all of that stuff is is still very
much a possibility
even if it is decoupled from the profit
motive and we can't even think about it
like that we were immediately we're like
well why not still have it be private
and just be cheaper overall and you know
take out some of the amenities I I don't
want to do that I want to make sure that
we build you know livable uh livable
housing that people want to live in
that is still kept at a low cost and and
more affordable
that's what I think can be done and it
is done in other places uh and I think
that it should be done in California it
would literally make this state like
the number one country to live in uh
because you know we have a massive GDP
where very powerful economy I think it's
like what fourth fifth largest economy
on the planet pretty much the fourth
largest economy yeah where did the money
go that's that's what I want to tell you
where the money goes the money goes to
you know
Gavin Newsom and other people's like
cousins and uncles that are like
contractors and developers that uh take
on and bid for these like uh viable
contracts of like massive infrastructure
projects that they have really no
intention of uh fully seeing through it
goes to our police force a gigantic
chunk of it goes to our police force
every time you drive over a pothole
think like you know cops got a
armored personnel carrier so you can't
have this pothole fixed it's it's
unimaginable even then part of me thinks
that crime is escalating to a point
where we need more police officers
because it's so prevalent like I've seen
you bring up a good point like first of
all crime is not escalating technically
that is even if you look at police
numbers police data crime is actually
decreasing but everywhere in the media
they're like oh my God crime is so bad
you would think that crime is worse in
California than it is in like South
Carolina no it's not South Carolina has
a much higher rate for example of
murders in New York can they
decriminalize a lot of the things in
California too no that's again a lot of
this stuff is
a lot of this stuff is portrayed in the
media in a way to draw out hysteria
towards it and then you see uh homeless
people like defecating on the street and
then you think oh my God the media is
correct crime is skyrocketing
homicides are up that's true
um certainly the main component though
is not our police budgets because police
budgets have gone up year over
year over year the Los Angeles Police
Department spends eight million dollars
a day just to operate eight million
dollars a day and hey if you get your
car broken into good luck you
know you call them up they're like sorry
nobody on the line you know but doesn't
that promote in a way more
crime because what I've seen again this
is me personally have seen this
firsthand but the level of crime out in
the open I've never seen that before in
my life as someone who worked like
Beverly Hills West Hollywood I've never
seen before someone in the broad
daylight smashing a window but over the
last two years I've seen and heard more
stories firsthand about people in broad
daylight being robbed for their watches
walking down the street in a crowded
space someone pulls up smashes a car
window grabs it and everyone's just kind
of standing there looking the police
won't respond to it because it's not
worth their time it's not yeah and also
they're super lazy let's be real
uh but
um yeah there's there's no other sector
where like that you
there's no other sector in which people
go oh yeah they they're just bad but we
got to give them more money but part of
me thinks it's just because there's it's
so prevalent because it's not enforced
because the the penalties are not as
strict as they should be for that level
of crime America houses the largest
number of uh you know caged people not
Free People prisoners on the planet we
are four percent of the entire planet's
uh population and yet we have 25 percent
of the entire planet's prisoner
population we have a very Draconian
attitude towards Crime and Punishment
and unfortunately in other countries
where they have a much more
understanding approach that focuses on
rehabilitation
they have better results of
reintegration they have lower recidivism
rates it is demonstrably failed our
carceral state is an abject failure
we've even profit we've even baked in
the profit incentive into it in the form
of private prisons which are just
abhorrent by uh you know other other
culture standards Norway literally has a
non-extradition treaty for uh many
crimes to the United States because they
consider U.S prisons to be a a regularly
violating human rights solitary
confinement and even like regular uh
prisons like regular jails like Rikers
and whatnot uh should be shut down but
are currently operating with like
millions of people I mean not Millions
but thousands of people that are uh that
are going through that jail system
without even a court date the we have we
have basically
proven time and time again that like
these kinds of you know we're gonna
tackle crime head-on by you know
beating people's heads in uh not working
is is just a failure in other places
where they don't do that it's not a
failure what is the main difference
though
it's because crime doesn't happen
because people are bad people certainly
there are still of course going to be
perverts freaks whatever you know
anti-social personality disorder uh
related crimes
but crime for the most part
is a consequence of your material
conditions that's why when there's more
poverty like in a state like South
Carolina there's more crime there's more
violent crime and the unfortunate
reality is that we rarely ever try to
tackle the underpinnings of why crime
happens and then we try to do this
Patchwork solution of like more police
enforcement which ironically then takes
funds away from the ways to maybe even
deal with why crime happens and you know
when there's less funding for after
school programs When there's less
funding for Education When there's less
funding for for uh you know any kind of
affordable solutions to the housing
crisis all of a sudden you have more
people that are desperate you have more
people that are just like willing to say
it I'm crazy I'm just gonna go you
know pass someone's head in and steal
their watch or Rob them at at gunpoint
that is a reality that has been
consistent and has been endlessly
pontificated on since ancient Greece the
the relationship that crime has with
poverty and yet for some reason we just
like to turn a blind eye to it here in
the United States and and refuse to
implement actual solutions that would
tackle it head on meanwhile there are
examples even if they are not
you know perfect even if they haven't
completely eviscerated crime right
um you know violent crime gun violence
uh and and even you know
um thefts grand larceny have are are
comparably much much better like those
rates are much much better in other
countries where they have social safety
nets why do you feel like and perhaps
this is just me making assumptions that
crime has gotten worse since kovid even
during the times that stimulus checks
and employment benefits were going out
that's a great question
um crime has historically uh gotten
lower year over year up until 2019 and
then in 2020 it actually
diminished dramatically because of the
things that you're mentioning and also
on top of uh on top of that people were
not able to travel as freely
um so it literally just completely
suppressed crime right a lot of economic
factors were were uh helpful in tackling
that aspect but then after uh the the
stimulus checks ran out and after uh
people were able to you know go back to
their regular order of business go and
and travel freely and and walk around it
seemed like in comparison to 2020 in
2021 crime started skyrocketing well yes
in comparison to 2020 yes the year after
and the year and since then crime has
gone up and now it's basically catching
up to 2019 levels and maybe depending on
homicide for example it's it's even
higher than 2019 levels but other than
that crime is still consistently lower
year over year it just depends on what
snapshot you're looking at but when you
see a big boost like that in the numbers
in comparison to the year prior and you
have a media that is like very excited
to you know ramp up the the hysteria and
the and the you know uh if it bleeds it
leads uh style attitudes they have when
they when they keep pushing for this
narrative and you have a police Union
that uh sees a lot of scrutiny when you
have police see a lot of scrutiny at the
national level through you know police
brutality becoming a more prominent uh
conversation Point
um what do you what are you supposed to
do against that how do you counter
against that narrative you say Well
they're trying to defund us
there has not been any significant
defunding movement that has existed in
any state any municipality across the
United States of America they say the
police have been defunded here in Los
Angeles for example I'm a taxpayer here
I'll probably pay for more Kev larves
and more guns than many of your viewers
and and maybe even some of them combined
let's be real uh and and I can tell you
with a certainty that police will have
not been defunded in Los Angeles as a
matter of fact they've gotten more funds
in comparison to the year prior and the
year prior to that as well
um their overtime benefits of
skyrocketed as well that's one way that
like police actually make a lot of their
money is overtime
um and uh I think what ended up
happening in order to like I guess uh
satiate the masses that were asking for
some level of accountability from the
police are neoliberal administrators
decided what do we do instead of giving
them 200 million extra dollars this year
we'll give them 150 million extra
dollars this year we'll just shave a
little bit off the top of what extra
money that we were going to give to the
police as a rate increase and then how
do they make up for that of course they
made up for that with covet funds which
Joe Biden has uh openly stated can be
used to pay overtime and the police
force to continue funding the police
don't they need more money because of
rising costs in general whether that be
for their families the cost of cars
gasoline Kevlar the cost of everything
has gone up so if they cut extra funds
that is also in addition to their own
cost probably going up by 20 well but
they haven't really cut funds like that
you know what I mean they they keep
funding the police uh very thoroughly
and and very handsomely at the
opportunity cost of not funding other
places that desperately needed
significantly more than the police as a
matter of fact like education like the
roads and the like every single thing
that you see that's why I always say
every single thing that you see in
California we're like how the is
this still like how is the pothole still
here you know what I mean that's crazy
yeah like fix the potholes it's
like yep can't because a lot of our
funds are currently being used elsewhere
um it's it's like a business everything
is a business right what do you do when
you're when you have a unlimited money
supply okay year over year you're gonna
find a way to spend it so you can keep
asking for it and even ask for more
everyone massages the numbers in that
regard if you've ever worked for a
corporation you know they do it all the
time they want to make sure that you
know their budgets look good they're
going to always find a way to spend it
yep there's never a moment where police
go maybe we should do a little bit of
belt tightening there's never austerity
towards police yeah there's only
austerity towards education year over
year I feel like that's not a problem
with the police that's just a problem
the whole California system where if any
company
government funded says I don't spend
this amount of money that I'm given I'm
not going to get more the next year and
I'm going to seem like a failure if I
get 20 million dollar budget I need to
spend the whole thing to be able to get
that again and if I spend 15 well now
I'm going to be limited to 15 the next
year audit it have some have some
number crunches in there go no
not anymore we're not doing this I think
we should do that I think that would be
great yeah I am
I'm in favor of implementing uh
efficiency protocols and eliminating
redundancy me too as as uh as vicious as
like a Bain Capital guy or you know a a
McKinsey consultant when it comes to uh
something that is as
expansive and not yielding the results
that it's supposed to like the police
force yeah what would you decriminalize
if you were to say one thing uh that
should not be enforced the way it is
I think if anything decriminalization is
a tricky subject to discuss because
I think that decriminalization without
anything else is just like you're not
doing anything you know what I mean if
if you're decriminalizing a certain
thing you also have to have preventative
mechanisms put in place
decriminalization of drugs for example
is profoundly successful in the nation
of Portugal right but what do they do
they didn't just decriminalize drug
usage right they also on top of that uh
created systems uh that they implemented
immediately like uh that that eliminated
needle sharing that basically offered up
a rehabilitation opportunities for
people who were you know regular
substance abusers and that was
profoundly successful in cutting back uh
both the usage and Drug assumption in
general but it was also uh profoundly
successful in in cutting back uh on you
know
secondary complications that come from
needle sharing like AIDS uh and and uh
you know hepatitis C and and the like
like a lot of uh transmittable diseases
that that people get
uh and people were able to go to rehab
if you consider drug usage for example
to be just a criminal act and if you if
you're you're only solution to drugs is
you know the police force and and
jailing
then you know you you arrive at the
problem that we have with the War on
Drugs what the drugs still want and the
remnants of that still exist
um
you know think about it like the way we
treat rich people like when a rich
person is a substance abuse problem they
don't see the the worst impacts they
don't they don't get thrown in
jail for the most part or brutalized by
police
they go to rehab and in a lot of
instances it might not even be
successful but in plenty of instances it
is it's just a more ethical way of
dealing with it and also a more
successful way of dealing with it if you
look to other countries that have
implemented similar processes so that's
one area that I would decriminalize
another one that I would decriminalize
is sex work for sure
again yeah I'd agree with both of those
yeah
why don't you think they've
decriminalized sex work wouldn't that
legitimize the industry prevent a lot of
sex trafficking make sure that people
are safer yeah absolutely not why do you
think we've not done that do you think
it's more of like a like a moral
religious America is very puritanical
and oftentimes we engage in like
nonsensical acts like even if the
majority of the public doesn't agree
with it not saying that like the public
loves sex work or anything but the
greatest example that comes to mind is
abortion you know what I mean it was
such an insane like such an insane thing
to do and you still have places like
Kentucky where you know it's a ballot
measure where they're like we are going
to codify abortion protections and then
uh and then the people overwhelmingly
vote for that right it's the most
democracy you can get a ballot measure
is the most direct democracy right you
go in you say no I want to protect
abortions and you press the
button or you fill it in
and and Kentucky overwhelmingly voted in
favor of of codifying and protecting
abortions the Kentucky attorney general
Mitch McConnell's very own guy uh you
know who's is turned around and said no
we're still gonna we're still gonna work
to criminalize abortion insane why are
we doing that well because we need to
have wedgie shoes we need to have a
culture War we need to have a back and
forth even if there is no such back and
forth when the overwhelming majority of
people think it's like completely
unjustifiable to criminalize abortion
and and allow women to have bodily
autonomy and and and you know not have
the government interfere with a medical
procedure
um but it doesn't matter because it gets
the base riled up it gets a very viable
constituency that the Republican party
needs to hold on to riled up and go out
and vote for it so that's why they have
to keep doing it over and over again and
sex work is not all that different
um it's a it's something that a lot of
people both engage in or consume uh and
and there's a sense of Shame surrounding
it because of our puritanical attitudes
and people don't usually care about it
they just have apathy for the most part
so it's a very easy group of people to
tackle especially when you know this is
an industry like you also correctly
pointed out where sex trafficking
happens right exploitation grooming and
the like or rape happens in this
industry just like it happens in every
other industry but um
you know decoupling that from sex work
which is done consensually amongst
adults is is uh very very important but
instead there's a deliberate effort by
you know
super conservative Ultra Christian
fundamentalist to never separate the two
to make sure that there's a conflation
so that they can consistently say what
you want sex crimes to continue you want
sex trafficking to continue we need to
destroy sex work in his entirety it's
every every single time there is a
coercion happening every single time
that there is uh you know a crime
happening anytime there's a you know any
kind of pornographic material being shot
what are some personal values that you
hold that is not also held by the
political party that you associate with
I mean I've there's a lot pretty much
everything I hold on to I don't think
the Democratic party genuinely cares
about they claim to care about it but I
don't think they care about any of it so
I would say almost all of what I believe
in the Democratic party is not
unsupportive what do you think the
Democratic party is doing right and what
do you think that they're doing wrong
and then can you also do that for the
Republican party yeah they're doing
everything wrong they're not doing
anything right Democratic party yes okay
yes they're doing everything wrong
um they are
they basically play the role of a
bottleneck for like any kind of genuine
Progressive momentum uh they don't offer
nearly enough labor protections like at
all they have not refunded the nlrb
after Donald Trump You Know defunded It
uh they are I mean there are notable
exceptions to this but overall the party
View and the party attitude towards like
even increasing the minimum wage or
things like that that could technically
be done through budget reconciliation
never came down to it because they
looked at the first tiny marginal hurdle
and said oh we can't do it because the
Senate parliamentarian said we can't do
it and it's like like
uh if you get down to the the the thick
of it or the weeds of it when you look
at all of these structural hurdles
the Republican Party eviscerates them
regularly okay they routinely will say
ah president I don't give a
we're gonna do it I mean look no further
than the Federalist Society from its
development to its Inception to all the
way to now where they have been able to
dismantle abortion Protections in the
Supreme Court that took like those 40
years uh long effort but it was
successful you know they don't give a
about what the impacts of this
might be on the ground so I think in
many respects the Republican Party does
a very good job of one creating uh
culture wars to fight and setting the
terms of that battle and then two
implementing measures that uh make it
feel like they're actually successful
and that they're giving something to
their audiences that they're giving
something to their constituencies
whereas the Democratic party constantly
is in a state of panic and defense but
that defense whenever they're in
positions of power never actually comes
to fruition and they just kind of let a
lot of it slide let a lot of it go
so as far as that goes I think whether
it be Environmental Protections Joe Joe
I was gonna call him Joe Brandon because
that's what I do on stream all that all
the time Joe Biden
um Joe Biden talks a big game about
Environmental Protection but then offers
you know Litany of pipelines to open up
um and uh you know no no such genuine
effort to like take away subsidies in
the fossil fuel industry and like
refocusing our efforts to become
competitive against China in the field
of like renewable energy is ever truly
made because the oil industry has
America in a Stranglehold you know they
can do whatever the they want but
under the Obama Administration the the
Democratic party had a super majority in
the Senate when they were trying to
implement ACA and then a senator died it
was replaced by a what's his name
oh this is the worst okay well I can't
figure it out there was one Senator
whose name is literally I'm blanking out
on right now it's very frustrating who
played the role of of the one guy who
was not going to vote for it and and you
know that's why the the Democrats had to
set up a Litany of compromises and
couldn't go far enough but the reality
is that as a unit as a whole they do not
want to make genuine system breaking
changes that they advocate for that I
consider to be a necessity
because they're still funded by the same
corporate benefactors for the most part
so you're of the mindset that there are
like this small group of Elites that
basically run the everything to a
certain extent I mean if you consider
that to be Capital owners in general
then yes I I do I think that this
country was built by Capital owners for
Capital owners this entire system of
governance is built for uh corporate
owners to get whatever they want
whatever their desires are and it's not
even like individual like it's more so
the structure itself benefits those who
are wealthy
um whether it be tax incentives when
you're richer uh and I I see it in my
personal experience as someone who made
twenty one thousand dollars the first
year my first year of employment to now
like I see the the many different
opportunities where like it is
significantly cheaper to be wealthy than
it is to be broke it is much more
expensive to be broke
um you know you're you're but don't you
feel like that also gives you
opportunity of upward Mobility no matter
where you start from
because you would be a great example of
that of coming to America
starting off earning very little but
finding a category that you excelled in
and innovating in that and providing
value in that and reaping the rewards of
that well luckily for us we don't have
to speculate on this because upward
social Mobility is something that people
track regularly and the United States
actually falls far significantly far
behind other countries that have social
safety nets every European social
democracy absolutely destroys the United
States on upward social Mobility because
when you don't have access to amenities
you are shutting off
a massive talent pool of people that uh
might be unimaginably creative but they
never get a chance to even express that
because they don't have the economic
freedom but then if that's the case why
wouldn't like Rich Kids predominantly
produce more than people growing up in
poverty because from what I've seen just
anecdotally people who grew up poor
without a lot of money or resources
often have a drive that people with
resources don't utilize or appreciate I
think that that probably comes from
having so much security that uh your
your drive is diminished like I think
you see a similar thing with immigrants
that are coming into this country
especially by the third generation full
assimilation has happened and you know
test results go down you've become a
full-blown American uh you you are you
don't have that same motivation of like
you know working super hard I think that
that's a byproduct but it doesn't bear
itself out in the D in the data in a
similar way
um like yeah sure super wealthy people
and their children oftentimes are
fail Sons you know it's a very
common thing that you see now of course
they're fail Sons
but they still end up
making their way uh through Society in a
way that like a poor person's child
would never be able to you know what I
mean like they're still
I mean George W Bush was the president
he is the ultimate fail son you know
what I mean he got to the tippy
top Donald Trump was a major fail son
every business that he got into he
up every single one uh his father
Fred Trump
famously had to consistently keep
loaning him money uh for his Casino
operations in Atlantic City over and
over again and then he still ended up
defaulting it because there were
measures set in place for the wealthy to
never truly fail right and if you take
advantage of that you can become
president one day so
you know as far as uh as far as the data
goes it it certainly shows that you know
sure there might be fail sons who are
abject failures ultimately that come
from like really wealthy backgrounds but
ultimately when you when you give more
opportunity to people more economic
freedoms of people especially people
that are coming from much poorer
backgrounds or middle class backgrounds
they make more with less
who do you think are political
commentators on the left that you don't
have a bunch of respect for you think
that they like they're basically too
aggressive or they lie or something like
that and who are some on the right that
you do and don't have respect for
I I don't have an issue with like any
political commentators on the left
overall I uh you know there might be
people that I don't really talk about in
general but other than that like I I no
matter what people say or no matter what
they even say about me whatever their
particular opinion might be I'm often of
the mindset that uh there's too much uh
sectarian infighting over like marginal
issues that people get very passionate
about and as long as someone is united
in
um you know trying to tackle the
problems that we talked about I don't
care what their political ideology is as
long as they're open-minded and
charitable so I don't really have an
issue with like any I guess leftist
commentators there aren't that many to
begin with a lot of them are my friends
uh you know the Chapo boys come to mind
uh you know they're great they have a
podcast the travel trap house if you
guys are unfamiliar
um and um that's it as far as right-wing
commentators goes I I think that there
are a lot of there is a predisposition
to
exaggerate
or even you know advocate for things
that you might not necessarily believe
in in your real life on the right
people say that about me all the time
which is funny but
um
I think that it is a much more viable
industry to be in if you want to just
like say whatever to an audience that's
like really really excited to hear it
and that's why you see a lot of what is
known as grifters on the right or people
who would like claim to be centrists for
example Temple will be a good example of
this he always says he's a liberal or
he's a Centrist but then he's like you
look at his commentary and you're like
are you really that's interesting
um
so
you know I think that the the entirety
of right-wing commentaries fear I I have
uh no respect for if that's the right
way to go about it I mean they're
they're great businessmen and women but
I think that they're
the way that they view the world or at
least the the propaganda that they cut
is genuinely bad I I don't agree and I
think that it stands against everything
I believe in stands against everything I
advocate for we might find common ground
on certain issues but even then I think
that that partnership is one that is
like short-lived for the most part I I
asked that because we're releasing this
episode back to back with an episode we
were just in Nashville we shot with
Brett Cooper if you know who she is uh
yeah that's uh that's fem Shapiro yeah
yeah sure yeah
young uh
young Ben Shapiro it's funny I um many
many moons ago someone was like yo this
person is like look at this young young
Ben Shapiro uh cut out a daily wire
uh and she was doing like a fake live
stream
and it looked kind of weird to me
because it was like not a real live
stream like but she was like responding
to chat and whatever and I've seen
um
I've seen some no space in memory card
oh well let's just that's totally fine
yeah okay well I've seen some materials
from like Turning Point USA where they
like openly are talking about how they
want to make sure that their influencers
resemble certain commentary and certain
styles of commentary and like they use
me as an example so I was like that's
kind of funny that they're like doing
like a fake live stream instead of a
real one yeah uh and and you know making
it seem like this person is like in her
room and talking when they're in a
studio
um but yeah I don't know uh what her
perspectives are at all I assume I would
not agree with them given what I know
about the daily wire
um there might be some common ground
maybe but uh yeah I don't really I don't
really know too much about her yeah she
said it was hot and so you know thank
you
yeah on a lie detector no yeah they were
doing like a lie detector test I saw the
clip
uh and uh you know so thanks our our
goal is really not to take a side but to
hear both perspectives and let the
audience come to their own decision and
be like a hundred percent respectful to
every person that comes on the show and
hear out other opinions that are you
know even if they're not our own but we
give them a chance and we listen listen
to them and hear them out so yeah all
right so I got two more questions
they're gonna be rapid fire questions
started off with something light okay
something easy what's the meaning of
life
what's the meaning of life
um the avoidance of pain and the
maximization of pleasure for all people
not just individually but for everyone
life is short
uh I think we should enjoy things we
should allow ourselves to enjoy things
and we should help others uh in that
similar Pursuit
okay and then of course I'm not saying
like eat donuts every goddamn
day and become a schlumber pleasure from
that though man well true but having
said that being healthy
is also very pleasurable and it will
allow you more opportunities to seek
Pleasures on top of that
so you're not cutting your life off you
know finally if you were to become
president what would you do
I would yeah it's a rapid fire question
there's a lot there's a lot I would do I
don't think the the president has all
that much power against the
like pre-existing and and like very
well-defined almost fossilized
institutional rules and regulations but
I guess one of the things that I would
try to do is uh make it much much easier
for workplaces to unionize and you know
develop workers councils at least so
that the working class can get at least
some percentage of the profits that they
generate back uh because I always say
it's not about being left it's not about
being right it's about what's fair and I
think that uh you know Collective action
in that regard offers opens up the
opportunity to at least advocate for
fairness in the workplace thank you so
much for coming on the podcast us on
this has been absolutely incredible it
means a lot that you came over here I
know I really appreciate it not
streaming too to come on here it's an
honor dude man well no problem I really
enjoyed this I like going in front of
different audiences you know I
appreciate it so thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time next
time nice thank you for this man I
really enjoyed that okay